Irgendwie kommt er einem bekannt vor.
Nun, 125 Jahre nach seinem Tod,
wird er ins richtige Licht gerückt.
Dieser Mann prägte die moderne
Schweiz, wie kein anderer.
Trotzdem kennen ihn die wenigsten.
Wer war Alfred Escher?
So genau weiss ich das auch nicht.
Ob es der mit den Zügen ist,
der die Bahn gründete,..
..oder der mit der Bank.
Er gründete
irgendeine wichtige Bank.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Alfred Escher, glaube ich.
Der mit den Zügen
und der mit der Bank, genau!
Und der mit der Gotthardbahn.
Mehr als ein Jahrhundert
war er vergessen,..
..in den Schulbüchern
wird er kaum erwähnt.
Zum 125-jährigen Gotthardjubiläum..
..wird er von der Wirtschaft
als Vordenker auf den Schild gehoben.
Sogar ein Zug wird nach ihm getauft.
Dieser Mann war ein Pionier,
dem unser Land viel verdankt.
Alfred Escher hat eigentlich
die moderne Schweiz angestossen.
Sein wirtschaftliches
und politisches Wirken..
..ist gigantisch,
ja geradezu monumental.
Die Erkenntnis,..
..dass er im 19. Jh. die heraus-
ragende Persönlichkeit war,..
..hat sich inzwischen
offenbar durchgesetzt.
Er war ein Arbeitgeber, der
dem Shareholder-Value verfallen war.
Es gab schlechte Arbeitsbedingungen.
Man beschaffte überall Kapital.
Am Ende ging es gut aus.
Die Gotthardbahn war
eine der besten Arbeitgeberinnen.
Dadurch bekam sie Vorbildcharakter.
Eine Jubiläumsfahrt und eine Reise
ins Leben des Wirtschaftspioniers.
Die Schweiz ist anfangs des 19. Jh.
ein beschaulicher Agrarstaat:
In den Städten
regiert das Grossbürgertum.
Alfred Escher wird 1819 in eine der
reichsten Familien Zürichs geboren.
Trotzdem ist er ein Aussenseiter.
Seine Familie trieb mit Spekulationen
halb Zürich in den Ruin..
..und zahlte die Schulden
nicht zurück.
Mit Wohnsitznahme im Belvoir
ausserhalb der Stadt..
..macht Vater Escher den Bruch mit
dem konservativen Zürich deutlich.
Sohn Alfred studiert Jura.
Durch den Bruch zwischen den Eschers
und dem konservativen Zürich..
..war es naheliegend,..
..dass Alfred Escher keine
politische Karriere machen konnte.
Er hatte nur eine Möglichkeit,
eine Alternative.
Das waren die Radikal-Liberalen
um Jonas Furrer.
Sie wollten eine neue Schweiz,
sie wollten alte Zöpfe abschneiden.
Ihnen schloss sich Alfred Escher an.
D.h., er war zu Beginn
ein Radikal-Liberaler,..
..der einen
starken Zentralstaat wollte,..
..der den Föderalismus
beenden wollte.
Er wollte
eine neue, moderne Schweiz.
Dadurch distanzierte er sich
von den Konservativen in Zürich.
1844 gewinnen die Radikal-Liberalen
in Zürich die Mehrheit..
..und kommen auch
in anderen Kantonen an die Macht.
Beseelt von ihren Visionen..
..und geprägt von der liberalen
Bewegung in ganz Europa..
..gründen sie 1848
den neuen Bundesstaat.
Bern wird Bundeshauptstadt.
Alfred Escher, erst 29,
wird in den Nationalrat gewählt.
Sein Freund Jonas Furrer wird
erster Bundespräsident der Schweiz.
Eschers Tatendrang macht ihn schnell
zum führenden Kopf der Liberalen.
Escher lebte in einer Zeit,
die es danach nicht mehr gab.
Escher konnte mit seinen liberalen
Freunden eine neue Schweiz bauen.
Eine moderne Schweiz,
von 1848 bis Anfang der 60er-Jahre.
In diesem kleinen,
wirtschaftsliberalen Zeitfenster,..
..als man die Weichen stellen,
etwas Neues bauen konnte.
Das war eine einmalige Chance
und er hat sie gepackt.
Er hat sich für das Land
und für den Kanton engagiert.
In Zürich findet der Gütertransport
immer noch auf dem Wasser statt.
Anstelle der noblen Bahnhofstrasse
gibts den stinkenden Fröschengraben.
Das umliegende Europa hingegen
verändert sich rasant.
Der Brite George Stephenson
hat die Eisenbahn erfunden.
Euphorie macht sich breit. Und
es wird gebaut, was das Zeug hält.
Die Schweiz jedoch ist im
Eisenbahnnetz ein weisser Fleck.
Mit einer einzigen Ausnahme:
die Spanisch-Brötli-Bahn.
23 km Schiene
zwischen Zürich und Baden.
Die Schweiz verschlief diese Frage.
Sie stritt sich um konfessionelle
Fragen, um Jesuiten-Fragen.
Aber den entscheidenden Fragen
der Zukunft,..
..der wirtschaftspolitischen
Entwicklung, ging man nicht nach.
Das stand nicht
auf der Prioritätenliste.
Als Alfred Escher 1848..
..Nationalrat und auch
Zürcher Regierungsrat wurde,..
..merkte er, dass man
die Schweiz voranbringen musste.
Und so
beschäftigte er sich allmählich..
..auch mit der Eisenbahn-Frage.
Alfred Escher lanciert die Diskussion
und sagt im Nationalrat 1849:
Es gibt Pläne,..
..gemäss denen die Bahnen
um die Schweiz herumgeführt werden.
Der Schweiz droht Gefahr,
umgangen zu werden.
Von seinem Belvoir in Zürich aus,..
..nimmt Escher Kontakt auf
mit anderen Kantonen und dem Ausland.
Die Frage ist: "Baut der Staat
oder bauen Private die Eisenbahn?"
Wie immer,
wenn Escher etwas beschäftigt,..
..führt er darüber regen Briefwechsel
mit seinen Vertrauten.
Er und sein Freund Johann Jakob
Rüttimann sind sich einig:
"Die Schweiz kann weder selbst bauen
noch Zinsen garantieren."
"Sie muss sich darauf beschränken ein
Expropriations-Gesetz zu erlassen."
Er positionierte sich hier ganz klar
auf der Seite der Privatwirtschaft.
Er sagte, dass nur Private
Eisenbahnen bauen konnten.
Denn der Rückstand der Schweiz
zum Ausland..
..sei mit einer staatlichen Bahn
nicht aufzuholen.
1852 verabschiedet der Nationalrat
das erste Eisenbahngesetz.
Es kommt wie Escher will:
Private dürfen Eisenbahnen bauen.
Aus heutiger Sicht
stiess Escher damit etwas an,..
..was die Zukunft der Schweiz
entscheidend prägte.
Er gründete und machte Dinge,
die es noch nicht gab.
Er holte die Schweiz damit
aus dem Rückstand.
Er half, den Rückstand
eines Agrarlandes,..
..das wenig Industrie besass,
aufzuholen.
Er legte den Grundstein
für die heutige Schweiz.
Es gab ja auch
die einzigartige Situation,..
..dass in Europa
ein Aufbruch stattfand.
Damals spielten ja die ganzen
infrastrukturellen Aspekte..
..eine sehr grosse Rolle.
So konnte man vielleicht einfacher
gewisse Leistungen erbringen.
Dank der Visionen, aber auch dank
der Willenskraft, die Escher hatte.
Das Eisenbahngesetz
führt zu einer Goldgräberstimmung.
Überall entstehen
private Eisenbahngesellschaften..
..und alle kämpfen
um die besten Linienführungen.
1855 alleine werden in der Schweiz
170 km Schiene verlegt.
Ist Alfred Escher bis 1852
v.a. politisch tätig,..
..steigt er nun auch als Unternehmer
ins Eisenbahngeschäft ein..
..und gründet die Nordostbahnen.
Sein Ziel: Möglichst schnell
Eisenbahnkilometer zu legen..
..und den Anschluss ans Ausland
zu schaffen.
Die Nordostbahn wird zur grössten
Eisenbahngesellschaft der Schweiz.
Die nötigen kantonalen Konzessionen
kann sich Escher,..
..der Nationalrat und Zürcher
Kantons- und Regierungsrat ist,..
..problemlos organisieren.
Schnell wird klar: Das Eisenbahn-
geschäft ist kapitalintensiv.
Das Geld für seine Expansionspläne
muss Escher im Ausland beschaffen.
Die ausländischen Kapitalgeber
diktierten Bedingungen.
Das gefiel Escher nicht.
Das widersprach
seiner politischen Vision,..
..der Unabhängigkeit der Schweiz.
Diese Unabhängigkeit,
wie er sie verstand..
..zeigte sich nicht nur darin,..
..dass man auch in der Schweiz
eine Eisenbahn baute.
Unabhängigkeit bedeutete für ihn,
dass es Schweizer Banken gibt,..
..dass die Schweiz entscheidet,
wo die Bahnlinie hindurchführt..
..oder dass Schweizer bestimmen,
welche Gesellschaften fusionieren.
Dass man das nicht in Paris,
London oder Frankfurt entscheidet.
Sondern in Zürich und der Schweiz.
1856 gründet Escher
die Kreditanstalt,..
..um damit
seine Nordostbahn zu finanzieren.
Kurz darauf folgt die Rentenanstalt.
Seinen Freund und Berater
Johann Jakob Rüttimann..
..nimmt er bei der Kreditanstalt
in den Verwaltungsrat.
Dass seine Unternehmen
Zürich, und damit die Schweiz,..
..zum grössten Finanzplatz Europas
machen würden, ahnt niemand.
Die Gründung der Kreditanstalt
war der entscheidende Coup.
Die Kreditanstalt war
die erste und älteste Grossbank,..
..die nicht nur
bei der Eisenbahn in Zürich..
..sondern in der ganzen Schweiz
Vorhaben unterstützte.
Sie stellte Geld zur Verfügung.
So konnte Escher
Einfluss darauf nehmen,..
..wer Geld bekam
und wer kein Geld bekam.
Deswegen hatte er mit seiner Bank
noch viel mehr Einfluss als vorher.
Alfred Eschers Jubiläumszug
ist in Luzern angekommen.
Wie vor 125 Jahren an der Eröff-
nungsfeier für die Gotthardbahn,..
..gehts aufs Schiff, bevor im Hotel
Schweizerhof das Diner serviert wird.
Was hält man in Politik und
Wirtschaft heute vom Pionier Escher?
Ohne Übertreibung muss man sagen,..
..er war er in dieser Zeitepoche
die zentrale treibende Kraft.
Speziell an ihm war, dass er
ein wirtschaftlicher Pionier war..
..aber sich gleichzeitig
politisch einbrachte.
Das macht seine Einzigartigkeit
noch zusätzlich aus.
Er hat seine Ideen
verfolgt und verwirklicht.
Er wird ja
unterschiedlich beschrieben,..
..auch als sehr rücksichtslos,
wenn er ein Projekt verfolgte.
Das zeichnet ihn auch aus.
Er liess sich nicht mehr
von seinem Ziel abbringen.
Das war wohl
der Grund für seinen Erfolg.
Gibt es heute noch solche Menschen?
Ja, es gibt noch Menschen,
die ein Ziel haben.
Die es auch
mit allen Mitteln verfolgen.
Aber man hat nicht mehr
dieselben Mittel dazu.
Mit der Nordostbahn, der Kredit-
anstalt und den politischen Ämtern..
..hat Escher in den 50er-Jahren
sehr viele Möglichkeiten,..
..um die Geschicke der Schweiz
zu lenken.
Auch nachdem er 1855 als Zürcher
Regierungsrat zurückgetreten ist,..
..nimmt er Einfluss auf
die wichtigen Geschäfte im Kanton.
Er gründete
politische Gesellschaften.
Parteien nach heutigem Verständnis
gab es damals noch nicht.
Escher bildete Plattformen
für seine politischen Freunde,..
..für seine liberalen Ideen.
Die Mittwochsgesellschaft
war eine der wichtigsten.
In der Donnerstagsgesellschaft..
..führte er seine Leute
aus Zürich und der Schweiz zusammen.
Dort diskutierte er personal-
und sachpolitische Geschäfte.
Dort fällte man Entscheide.
Dadurch gingen wichtige Geschäfte im
Kantonsrat schnell über die Bühne.
In wenigen Minuten
war etwas diskutiert,..
..da die Weichen bereits
vorher gestellt worden waren,..
..in der Mittwochs-
oder Donnerstagsgesellschaft.
Die meisten dieser Geschäfte werden
durch den Eisenbahnbau ausgelöst.
Dank Eschers Einfluss..
..kommt z.B. die Eidg. Technische
Hochschule, die ETH, nach Zürich.
Für die Erweiterung des Schienen-
netzes braucht es Ingenieure..
..und diese müssen
irgendwo ausgebildet werden.
1861 lanciert Escher auch das Projekt
für einen neuen Hauptbahnhof.
Nicht ganz uneigennützig,
denn nur so kann er sicherstellen,..
..dass Zürich als Wirtschafts-
und Industriestandort wichtig bleibt.
Zürich boomt.
Alfred Escher ist
auf dem Höhepunkt seiner Macht.
Zar von Zürich oder heimlicher König
der Schweiz wird er genannt.
Mit seinem Einfluss und seinen Ämtern
in der Privatwirtschaft..
..kann er schalten und walten,
wie er will.
Überall zieht er die Fäden.
Aufgrund der wirtschaftspolitischen
Plattformen..
..konnte er
die entsprechenden Ämter..
..mit seinen politischen Freunden,
den Liberalen, besetzen.
In der Wirtschaft konnte er
Verwaltungsratssitze besetzen.
Er sorgte natürlich dafür,..
..dass seine Freunde
in diese Funktionen gewählt wurden.
Aber auch im Bundesrat
kann er jederzeit Einfluss nehmen.
So schreibt er
an den Bundesrat Jakob Dubs,..
..als es um die Bewilligung
für die Kreditanstalt geht:
"Wenn du die beiliegende
Eingabe der Handelskammer..
..zuhanden der Regierung
zu überweisen die Güte hättest,..
..könnte sie heute Nachmittag
noch behandelt werden."
Von den Freunden im Bundesrat
wird er über alle Details informiert.
Der Eisenbahnbaron weiss alles
und kann entsprechend handeln.
Der heutige Verkehrsminister Moritz
Leuenberger hat nicht so viel Macht:
Auch ich ertappe mich beim Wunsch,..
..möglichst schnell und ohne
lästige Kommissionssitzungen..
..und Abstimmungen
etwas durchziehen zu können.
So wie es
ein freier Unternehmer tun kann.
Aber wir leben in einer Direkten
Demokratie. Und ich glaube an diese.
Die Direkte Demokratie
war in der Lage,..
..ein Riesenprojekt
wie die NEAT zu beschliessen.
Und zwar in vielen Abstimmungen.
Das Projekt wurde beschlossen,
die Finanzierung, die LSVA,..
..die internationale Einbettung.
Alles durch Abstimmungen.
Jetzt wird gebaut
und alle beneiden uns.
Alle diese Hürden
muss Escher noch nicht nehmen.
"Warum wurde er nicht selbst
Bundesrat?", fragt man sich.
Tatsächlich wird er 2-mal angefragt,
winkt aber immer ab.
Er war im Belvoir zu Hause.
Er war ein Familienmensch
mit starker Beziehung zur Mutter.
Schon in seiner Jugend,
als Student, zeigte sich,..
..immer wenn er
von zu Hause weg musste,..
..bei Auslandssemestern
oder auf Reisen..
..dass er, überspitzt
formuliert, krank wurde.
Aus diesem Grund sagte er auch,
er wolle nicht nach Bern,..
..sondern in Zürich bleiben.
Die Jubiläumsgesellschaft
ist im Hotel Schweizerhof angekommen.
Das Diner ist bis in alle Details..
..dem Fest zur Gottharderöffnung
vor 125 Jahren nachempfunden.
Gastgeberin Credit Suisse, die
ihren Gründervater hiermit ehrt,..
..scheut keine Kosten und Verwal-
tungsratspräsident Kielholz glaubt,..
..dass es mit dem Aufschwung
so weitergeht wie zu Eschers Zeiten.
Die Zeit Alfred Eschers
war der Zeitraum,..
..als es in der Schweizer
Gesellschaft grosse Schübe gab.
Wir stehen
vor einem grossen Schub,..
..denn seit einiger Zeit
wandern hochqualifizierte Leute ein.
Diese werden
unser Land weiterbringen.
Escher befindet sich
auf dem Höhepunkt seiner Macht.
Auch privat scheint sich
beim ehrgeizigen Visionär..
..alles zum Guten zu wenden.
1857 heiratet er
die 20 Jahre jüngere Augusta Uebel.
Er heiratete keine Zürcherin.
Er hätte ja versuchen können, das
zerrüttete Verhältnis zu Zürich..
..mit einer geschickten
Heiratspolitik zu kitten.
Das tat er nicht, er heiratete
keine Zürcherin oder Winterthurerin.
Er heiratete als 39-Jähriger
eine 19-jährige Deutsche,..
..die in Zürich keiner kannte,
die hier nicht verwurzelt war.
Bald kommt seine erste Tochter Lydia
zur Welt, benannt nach seiner Mutter.
1861 wird Eschers zweite Tochter
Hedwig geboren.
Aber sein Glück ist von kurzer Dauer.
Nun folgt eine ganze Reihe
von schweren Schicksalsschlägen:
Eineinhalb Jahre nach der Geburt
stirbt Tochter Hedwig.
An seinen alten Freund und
Bundesrat Jakob Dubs schreibt Escher:
"Heute früh wurde Hedwig von
einer Lungenentzündung befallen,..
..die so heftig wurde, dass sie ihr
schon um 11.30 Uhr zum Opfer fiel."
"Du kannst dir denken,
wie gross unser aller Schmerz ist."
"Ich weiss, dass du
in treuer Freundschaft mitfühlst."
Aber es kommt noch schlimmer:
2 Jahre später muss Escher
seine junge Frau zu Grabe tragen.
Als sein Freund
Kaspar Lebrecht Zwicky..
..ihr zu Ehren seine Tochter
Auguste nennt, ist Escher gerührt:
"Du kannst dir denken,
dass ich durch den Namen..
..der Neugeborenen näher komme."
"Lass mich
hierüber nicht weiter sprechen."
"Ich sitze in
der Verfassungsrevisions-Kommission..
..und muss der Wehmut
Meister zu werden suchen."
Nach nur 7 Jahren Ehe steht Escher
mit Tochter Lydia alleine da.
Lydia war häufig am Paradeplatz
in der Kreditanstalt.
Sie sass dabei,
wenn die Verwaltungsräte kamen.
Sie begleitete den Vater
an Sitzungen der Nordostbahn,..
..an Sitzungen des Direktoriums.
Das Mädchen wuchs also nicht so auf,
wie es andere Mädchen damals taten.
Diese Umstände
werden Lydias Leben prägen.
Sie zeigen auch
eine Seite von Escher,..
..die in den Jubiläums-Feierlich-
keiten schnell vergessen wird.
Man sprach nie
über Eschers Familiensituation.
Man weiss ja,..
..dass die familiäre Situation mit
der Tochter nicht ganz einfach war.
Heute würde man sagen, sie war von
einem sehr starken Vater geprägt.
Sie konnte sich nie so entwickeln,..
..dass sie später im Leben
bestehen konnte.
Ich bin zwar
ein grosser Fan von Escher,..
..aber man darf dabei
nicht vergessen,..
..dass es bei ihm
auch negative Seiten gab.
Ende 1860
ändert sich auch politisch einiges.
Die Liberalen verlieren die Mehrheit
in der Regierung und im Parlament.
Von Eschers Freunden
und Verbündeten..
..stirbt einer nach dem anderen.
"Wir werden immer weniger",
schreibt Escher.
Demokraten betreten das politische
Parkett und gewinnen an Boden.
Die Volksrechte Initiative
und Referendum werden eingeführt.
Eschers Allmacht beginnt zu bröckeln.
Es gab dann zwangsläufig
überall Menschen, Politiker,..
..die in Sachfragen
gegen Alfred Escher waren.
Hinzu kam noch,
dass es immer mehr gab,..
..die seine Dominanz einfach
nicht mehr akzeptierten.
Die Opposition gegen ihn
formiert sich nur langsam.
Noch funktioniert das System Escher..
..und der Unermüdliche stürzt sich
in sein grösstes Projekt.
Er schreibt:
"Eine schweizerische Alpenbahn
erscheint mir immer wichtiger."
"Es wird mir immer klarer,
dass die Schweiz..
..ohne eine
die Alpen durchbrechende Eisenbahn..
..zu einem vom Weltverkehr umgangenen
Eiland herabsinken müsste."
Schon seit den 50er-Jahren gibt es
Pläne für eine Nord-Süd-Achse.
Escher favorisiert
die Lukmanier-Variante.
Das ändert sich in den 60er-Jahren.
Es änderte sich,..
..als die Gotthard-Befürworter
konkrete Projekte vorlegten.
Es wurde machbar.
Man sah, dass der Gotthard
nicht teurer war als der Lukmanier.
Und der Gotthard
war auch technisch machbar.
Als klar wurde,
dass der Gotthard bezwingbar war,..
..bekam der Gotthard
viel grössere Chancen.
Denn er liegt viel besser.
Er liegt im Nord-Süd-Verkehr,
in der Mitte der Schweiz.
Der Grossteil der Kantone
lag auf der Seite des Gotthards.
Das Seilziehen in Bern um die
richtige Nord-Süd-Route dauert Jahre.
Nicht viel anders als heute.
Auch bei der NEAT rang man
um die richtige Route -
zwischen Gotthard und Lötschberg.
Verkehrsminister Moritz Leuenberger:
Ich habe das Gefühl,
hier hat sich nicht viel geändert.
Es gibt immer noch diese Rivalität
zwischen Lötschberg und Gotthard.
In der Romandie sagt man,..
..der Gotthard fresse das Geld
für den öffentlichen Verkehr weg.
Als der Lötschberg-Basistunnel
eröffnet wurde,..
..planten die Gotthard-Anhänger,..
..ihre 125-Jahr-Jubiläumsfeier
eine Woche früher abzuhalten,..
..um besser
von den Medien zu profitieren.
Dagegen musste man intervenieren.
Es ist wie Don Camillo und Peppone.
Es hat sich nicht viel geändert.
Damals spielte am Schluss..
..Bismarcks Deutschland
das Zünglein an der Waage:
Aus aussenpolitischen,
militärstrategischen Gründen..
..kam für Preussen und das Deutsche
Reich nur der Gotthard infrage.
Der Lukmanier
an der Grenze zu Österreich-Ungarn..
..passte militärstrategisch
nicht in Bismarcks Konzept.
Bismarck sagte:
"Wir beteiligen uns nur
an einer Nord-Süd-Verbindung,..
..wenn der Gotthard gebaut wird."
Der Druck Bismarcks ist rückblickend
ein Segen für die Schweiz.
Dies ist der allgemeine Tenor
an der Gotthard-Jubiläumsfeier.
Der Gotthardtunnel,..
..der von der Bedeutung her mit
dem Suez-Kanal verglichen wurde,..
..war nicht nur das Tor zu Italien,
sondern zur Welt.
Ein eigentlicher Globalisierungs-
schritt für die Gesellschaft,..
..auch wenn man das
noch nicht so nannte.
Alfred Escher
wird zur treibenden Kraft..
..und zum Lobbyisten
für das Gotthardprojekt.
Er schreibt:
"In der Schweiz
war schwere Arbeit zu verrichten."
"Zu den Schwierigkeiten
kamen noch die Kantone,..
..mit denen man zu tun hatte."
"In jedem
eine andere Anschauung,..
..und doch musste alles
unter einen Hut gebracht werden."
Im Bundesrat allerdings weht Escher
ab 1866 ein schärferer Wind entgegen.
Mit dem Aargauer Emil Welti gibt es
einen neuen starken Mann in Bern.
Welti steht
für eine neue Politikergeneration.
Der Jurist aus Zurzach diente sich
aus dem Kleinbürgertum herauf.
Er gehört nicht mehr
zur Gründergeneration,..
..sondern
zu den Bewahrern und Verwaltern,..
..die einen stärkeren Zentralstaat
fordern.
Ganz im Gegensatz zu Escher.
Dieser will die Gotthardbahn durch
eine private Trägerschaft bauen.
Welti rang sich zum Privatbau durch.
Im Kern war er
auf der Seite des Staatsbaus.
Er stand auf der Seite jener,
die sagten,..
..der Staat müsse
die Bahngesellschaften übernehmen.
Aber als Welti 1866
in den Bundesrat gewählt wurde,..
..besass er diese Stärke noch nicht.
Er sah,
wie die Machtverhältnisse waren.
Und die waren noch
auf der Seite Eschers,..
..auf der Seite jener, die den
privaten Bahnbau favorisierten.
Auch wenn
die Opposition gegen Escher wächst,..
..er bleibt
das Zugpferd für das Gotthardprojekt.
An ihm kommt niemand vorbei.
Der Bundesrat musste sich
jetzt dazu überwinden,..
..sich für Escher zu entscheiden.
Man wusste,
es gibt keine andere Wahl.
Aber politisch war es heikel.
Der Bundesrat rang sich dazu durch..
..und beauftragte Welti, die Ver-
handlungen mit Escher aufzunehmen.
Emil Welti kam wie ein Headhunter
zu Escher und fragte ihn,..
..ob er die Direktionsposition
des Gotthard-Unternehmens übernehme.
Und Escher tat es.
Seine Ämter in der Privatwirtschaft
will er behalten.
Nur bei der Nordostbahn
tritt er zurück,..
..wird aber Verwaltungsratspräsident.
Die mühselige Reise über den Gotthard
soll bald ein Ende haben.
1871 wird die Gotthardgesellschaft..
..als private Aktiengesellschaft
gegründet.
Italien, Deutschland und die Kantone
beteiligen sich an der Finanzierung.
Bern will aber mitreden beim Fahr-
plan, Güterverkehr und den Finanzen.
Ein Konstrukt, das heute
nie mehr in Frage kommen würde.
Ein grosses Bauwerk wie die NEAT..
..kann nur
durch den Staat durchgeführt werden.
Nur der Staat
kann die grossen Risiken,..
..die ein solches Werk mit sich
bringt, tatsächlich übernehmen.
Der Staat regelt die Finanzierung,..
..damit es nicht zu Überraschungen
zu Lasten der Steuerzahler kommt.
Mit finanziellen Überraschungen
muss man beim Bau schon fast rechnen.
Der Genfer Ingenieur Louis Favre
erhält den Auftrag.
Am Anfang läuft alles rund,
aber bald ist klar:
Die veranschlagten 187 Mio. Fr.
reichen nicht aus.
Das war kein gewöhnlicher Tunnel.
Man musste
einen 15 km langen Tunnel..
..durch das Gotthardmassiv
hindurch bauen.
Geologisch
hatte man das nicht im Griff.
Man hatte auch
keine Reserven eingeplant.
Das führte, aus heutiger Sicht,
von Anfang an klar dazu,..
..dass es zu Kostenüberschreitungen
kommen musste.
Der Bau des Gotthardtunnels
fällt in eine Zeit,..
..wo der Eisenbahnbau in
ganz Europa in eine Krise schlittert.
Der Markt ist überhitzt,
die Aktienkurse fallen.
Escher erhält viele böse Briefe
von enttäuschten Aktionären.
In dem Augenblick, als die Kurse
und Dividenden zurückgingen,..
..war man unzufrieden, frustriert.
Man meinte,
falsch investiert zu haben.
Dass führte dazu, dass
in breiten Kreisen der Bevölkerung..
..das Misstrauen
gegen diese Spekulationen,..
..gegen die Eisenbahngesellschaften
immer grösser wurde.
Man suchte natürlich
einen Sündenbock.
Das war der Kopf dieser
Eisenbahngesellschaften.
Der Direktionspräsident
Alfred Escher.
Jetzt rächt sich,..
..dass Escher so lange
so viel Macht auf sich vereinigte..
..und dass er sie
so rücksichtslos ausübte.
Das liberale Establishment
kommt extrem unter Druck:
In Zürich
übernehmen die Demokraten die Macht.
Wäre ich
ein Zeitgenosse Eschers gewesen,..
..hätte ich mich sicher auf die
Seite der Demokraten geschlagen.
Ich hätte die Bundesbarone
vehement bekämpft.
Sie waren zwar Republikaner,
aber Demokraten waren sie nicht.
Sie waren Pioniere,
sie schufen Neues,..
..aber sie gingen über Leichen.
Die Arbeitsbedingungen
am Gotthard sind schlecht.
Das Jahrhundertwerk
fordert viele Opfer.
Die Kosten laufen
je länger je mehr aus dem Ruder.
Bundesrat Emil Welti beginnt,
sich von Escher zu distanzieren.
Aufgrund dieser Situation
zeigte sich für Welti..
..dass ein Sündenbock nötig war.
Das konnte aus Weltis Sicht
nur Alfred Escher sein.
Denn wäre es nicht Escher gewesen,
wäre nur er selbst infrage gekommen.
Er musste jemanden finden, der
diese Verantwortung auf sich nahm.
Für Welti konnte das
nur Alfred Escher sein.
Die Kostenüberschreitungen
werden für Escher zum Stolperstein.
Aus heutiger Sicht
ist es erstaunlich,..
..dass trotz aller Unwägbarkeiten..
..die Kosten nur
um 20 Mio. Fr. überschritten wurden.
Diese 20 Mio. Fr., gerechnet auf
das ganze Budget von 187 Mio. Fr.,..
..machen nicht mehr als
11 % Kostenüberschreitung aus.
Heutzutage gibt es sehr wenige
Projekte dieser Grösse,..
..welche die Kosten
nur um 11 % überschreiten.
Verglichen mit der NEAT
ist das tatsächlich nicht viel.
Die NEAT kommt
rund doppelt so teuer wie geplant.
Nur hat man heute
originelle Möglichkeiten,..
..um Mehrkosten nicht als Über-
schreitungen deklarieren zu müssen.
Kostenüberschreitungen in dem Sinne,
wie es sie damals gab,..
..gibt es bei uns nicht.
Wir haben daraus gelernt
und es so geplant,..
..dass es nicht möglich ist.
Natürlich wird die NEAT
teurer als geplant,..
..aber weil Mehrausgaben
bewusst beschlossen wurden...
Z.B. für eine zweite Röhre
für den Ceneri-Tunnel..
..oder eine Anschlussvariante Uri.
Das waren demokratische Beschlüsse.
Nur in einem Punkt
entstanden unvorhergesehene Kosten.
Das betrifft die Ausschreibungen und
Rekurse von unterlegenen Firmen,..
..was empfindliche Verzögerungen
herbeiführte.
1877 wird es für Alfred Escher
richtig ungemütlich.
Es hagelt
Kritik und Häme von allen Seiten.
Das Millionen-Loch in der
Gotthard-Kasse muss gestopft werden..
..und der Bundesrat
um Emil Welti beginnt,..
..Escher systematisch zu demontieren.
Seine Machtfülle sei hinderlich..
..für die nötigen Mehrheiten
zur Nachfinanzierung,..
..schreibt Welti an Escher.
Er fordert von ihm den Rücktritt aus
dem Verwaltungsrat der Kreditanstalt.
Sie versuchten, Escher in eine
schlechte Position zu drängen.
Das war nicht einfach,..
..denn Escher hatte immer noch
seine wirtschaftspolitische Macht.
Er war die wirtschaftliche Macht.
Es war sehr schwierig,..
..eine solch dominante Person
auf die Seite zu schieben.
Alfred Escher tritt zurück,
um, wie die Kreditanstalt schreibt,..
.."seine Kraft ganz dem gefährdeten
Unternehmen des Gotthards zu widmen."
Als etwas später der Nachtragskredit
zur Gotthardfinanzierung..
..von jedem Kanton - also auch
von Zürich - bewilligt werden muss,..
..kommt Weltis Chance,
Alfred Escher ganz loszuwerden.
Das Zürcher Volk
musste sich entscheiden,..
..ob es die Nachsubvention
bewilligen wollte oder nicht.
Escher sagte dann,
er wolle sofort informiert werden,..
..wenn die Resultate bekannt würden,
egal zu welcher Zeit.
Um 2.30 Uhr war es dann so weit.
Der Bürodiener
kam zu Escher ins Belvoir,..
..um 2.30 Uhr morgens.
Er fand Alfred Escher
an seinem Schreibtisch.
Escher arbeitete.
Der Bürodiener
musste dann Escher mitteilen,..
..dass sein eigener Kanton, Zürich,
die Vorlage klar abgelehnt hatte.
Das war für Alfred Escher
sehr schmerzhaft.
Gemäss Überlieferung stand Escher
an seinem Schreibtisch..
..fasste sich
mit der Hand an die Stirn.
Mit der anderen Hand
stützte er sich ab.
Er stiess er einen Schrei aus,
trampelte mit den Füssen und sagte:
"Auch du, mein Zürich!"
Welti nutzt
die politische Niederlage Eschers,..
..um ihm den entscheidenden Schlag
zu versetzen:
Er zwingt ihn,..
..als Präsident der
Gotthard-Gesellschaft zurückzutreten.
"Ich muss ohne Umschweife sagen,..
..dass einige
der besten Freunde unserer Sache..
..Ihren Rücktritt für das Gelingen
für erforderlich halten",..
..schreibt Welti.
Letztlich haben Welti
und seine freisinnigen Freunde..
..Alfred Escher geopfert.
Es muss gesagt werden, dass
die Freisinnigen, Eschers Partei,..
..ihn auf die Schlachtbank
geführt haben.
Nur 4 Tage später legt Escher sein
Amt als Direktionspräsident nieder.
Es ist die bitterste Niederlage
seines Lebens.
Der visionäre Wirtschaftspionier
ist gescheitert.
Alfred Eschers Fall
hätte tiefer nicht sein können.
Wie interpretiert
man heute seinen Niedergang?
2 Dinge in der Schweiz
sind schon sehr alt.
Der Föhn und der Neid.
Der Neid ist ein ganz wesentlicher
Punkt, weshalb er scheiterte.
Aber auch der Umbruch,
die Demokratisierung, die stattfand.
Und auch die Tatsache, dass,
sobald eine Sache gross wird,..
..allen, die den Kopf rausstrecken,
dieser abgeschlagen wird.
Für Zürich ist typisch, dass jenen,
die angeblich scheiterten,..
..heute ein Denkmal gesetzt wird.
Wie Hans Waldmann und Alfred Escher.
Wir sind ein Volk von Kontrolleuren.
Jeder schaut,..
..dass der andere nicht mehr hat
als er selbst.
Das ist vielleicht ein alter Brauch
eines kleinräumigen Landes.
Escher wurde schliesslich ein Opfer
dieser Kleingeistigkeit im Land.
Aber er hatte es probiert
und hatte Erfolg.
Er scheiterte letztlich
nicht an sich oder dem Projekt.
Die Gesellschaft holte ihn ein
und brachte ihn dorthin zurück,..
..wo sie ihn haben wollte.
Am Boden.
Alfred Escher
wird vollständig demontiert.
Welti will ihn nicht einmal
im Verwaltungsrat dabeihaben.
Emil Welti fragte Escher gar nicht,
ob er in den Verwaltungsrat wollte.
Das war
eine weitere Enttäuschung Eschers.
Nicht nur
der erzwungene Rücktritt,..
..sondern auch, dass er trotz seiner
Verdienste um die Gotthardbahn..
..1878 nicht einmal in
den Verwaltungsrat eingeladen wurde.
Escher beklagt sich
bei Welti darüber.
"Ich bin überzeugt,..
..dass man mir die Genugtuung
schuldig gewesen wäre,..
..mich in den Verwaltungsrat
zu wählen,..
..und dass man
ein Unrecht an mir beging.
Welti antwortet:
"Hätte ich gewusst,
dass Sie eine Wahl erwarten,..
..hätte ich Ihnen entschieden
von einer solchen abgeraten."
"Sie konnten diese Wahl nur als
Ausdruck der Anerkennung wünschen."
"Aber diese
kann Ihnen niemand erteilen..
..als die öffentliche Meinung
oder die unparteiische Geschichte."
Aber es kommt noch dreister:
Als 1880 der langersehnte Durchstich
am Gotthard erfolgt,..
..bekommt Escher von Emil Welti
nichts als ein dürres Telegramm.
Zur Durchstichsfeier in Göschenen
und Airolo wird er nicht eingeladen.
Er wurde 1880
mit keinem Wort erwähnt.
Eschers Name
fiel an den Feierlichkeiten nicht.
Damit kam Escher nie zurecht.
Das traf ihn bis ins Innerste.
Bis 1882 musste er
immer wieder in die Kur.
Er konnte seine Mandate
z.T. auch wieder wahrnehmen.
Er ging auch wieder nach Bern.
Aber letztlich
erholte er sich nicht mehr..
..von den verschiedenen Schlägen,
die er einstecken musste.
Alfred Escher stirbt
63-jährig am 6. Dezember 1882,..
..aufgebraucht und ausgebrannt.
Der Totenzug mutet an
wie ein Staatsbegräbnis.
Sein Freund,
der Theologe Alexander Schweizer..
..sagt
in der Abdankungsrede in Zürich:
"Grosse Männer
sind nicht leicht fähig,..
..andere aufkommen zu lassen..
..oder zur gleichen Höhe
heranzubilden."
"Treten sie ab, fehlt es
an entsprechendem Ersatz."
"Eschers Grösse leuchtete nicht,
ohne diesen Schatten zu werfen."
Die Zeitungen würdigen ihn
mehrheitlich mit Respekt.
Die NZZ z.B. schreibt:
"Die Republik hat einen ihrer
hervorragendsten Bürger verloren,..
..der sich
mit seltener Hingabe und Tatkraft..
..den öffentlichen Dingen widmete."
Kaum ist er tot,
ist man wieder nett zu ihm.
Er bekommt sogar ein Denkmal
auf dem Zürcher Bahnhofplatz.
Seine Demontage zu Lebzeiten
führt aber doch dazu,..
..dass er lange Zeit
in Vergessenheit gerät.
Jetzt, 125 Jahre später,
anlässlich des Gotthardjubiläums,..
..macht man gut,
was damals versäumt wurde.
Visionäre wie Alfred Escher
brauchen wir.
Unternehmer und Politiker,
die Zusammenhänge erkennen..
..und verhindern,..
..dass die Schweiz auf das
Abstellgleis der Geschichte gerät.
Und so trifft ein, was Emil Welti
Alfred Escher damals prophezeite:
..die späte Satisfaktion
der unabhängigen Geschichte.
Auch bei den grossen Komponisten
braucht es z.T. Jahrzehnte,..
..wenn nicht Jahrhunderte,
bis ihre Bedeutung erkannt wird.
Man darf nicht vergessen:
125 Jahre tönt zwar nach viel,..
..aber in der Geschichte der Mensch-
heit ist es nur ein kleiner Moment.
Trotzdem stellt sich die Frage,..
..warum Alfred Escher ausgerechnet
jetzt ein solches Revival erlebt.
In Zeiten der Verunsicherung
der Bürger, von grossen Problemen,..
..neigen viele dazu,
nach einem starken Mann zu rufen.
Einem Deus ex machina,
der alle Probleme auf einmal löst.
Aber das ist wie Superman und
es passt nicht in die heutige Zeit.
Die heutige Zeit
ist die Zeit der NEAT..
..und der Direkten Demokratie mit
ihrer geteilten Verantwortlichkeit.
Aber wünscht sich der heutige Ver-
kehrsminister nicht auch ein Denkmal?
Nicht  e i n  Verkehrsminister ist
für so ein Projekt verantwortlich,..
..sondern
die ganze Direkte Demokratie.
So gesehen
steht mir sicher kein Denkmal zu.
Und ich will keines, denn da
scheissen doch nur die Tauben drauf.